[Musique]
enfin des enfants bon choix
o o l'air pur de la campagne
patron je descend vite rejoindre mes
amis je sens qu'il m'attend oui vas-y
fit nounours mais ne tarde pas trop
compter sur moi je ne vous ferai pas
trop attendre mais il faut quand même
que je les vois quelques instants mes
amis au 16 arrêts ou les châles europe
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
au
top ces nounours donnez vous la peine
dans très chère amie pour cela nos
missions
c'est quelque chose de bon aux grands
gourmands tu penses toujours à manger
toi juliette a vient regarde bien
nounours j'ai adoré ce n'est pas
possible
mais oui tu vas voir
attention un petit julietta
et 3
mon petit oiseau après sa volée mon
petit mot doux repris son rôle à
frissonner laval est impuissant elle a
volé deux appuis ça vaut mieux
[Musique]
se tapit y ait sur un oranger il se
tortiller tour d'orange et sur renault
alors là katsura dollars là que sur mac
en danger
la branche a cassé il oiseaux ta tombe
et le brunch au cosec lilloise au top
nyoiseau témoin savall à nouveau au top
elle voulait que l'oiseau ta tomber
mon petit oiseau ou te plaît c'est mon
petit oiseau foot est tout bleu tout est
alors là où te tue oh là là te coûte
elle te blesser
je ne suis qu'à celles elle il tente où
le hockey je me suis comme celle des
ports d'où l'on vient et au retour à
laval être étendu à la baule est
détendue
pièce
montée petit oiseau veux te soigner mon
territoire dont peut-être
là que tu te voilà petit à soigner
je veux me soigner et mon mari et je
veux me soigner et mono et mamadou à la
valette et madame madeleine marillet
bravo julietta et bravo les enfants elle
est très jolie votre chanson c'est moi
qui l'avait apprise mon ami sauriez-vous
musiciens dada à mes heures perdues je
travaille mon sale fais une camarade
haha
mais je crois qu'il est l'heure pour les
petits oiseaux
d'aller au lit et je me sens
[Musique]
venu nous
au revoir
hamida temps mes hommages camarades que
la nuit vous apporte calme et
tranquillité
[Musique]
alors nounours qu'est ce que tu fais
quoi ward patron je prends ma faut lui
nous voyons nous nous tu n'es pas un
petit oiseau que thomas
enfant au liban oui en août bonne nuit
des enfants allez vite vous coucher et
feuilletons bourreurs
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]
m
avant
mon
[Musique]